it was past my bedtime but who could
sleep with a paige turner like
meditations on first philosophy by renee
descartes
descartes was more than just a
philosopher he was also the
mathematician
who invented the cartesian plane if
you've ever enjoyed that x
squared plus y squared equals k is a
circle you can say merci beaucoup to mr
descartes
hello bonjour sheldon bonjour rene
please sit
i see you're reading a book on
philosophy by aristotle
i am and it is garbage
aristotle is how you say a punk
i'm also having trouble with my
philosophy professor
she says that we don't know if science
is true
without science we know nothing no
difference and
the dogs and kitties in the street
wandering around in a
fog of ignorance with the woofings and
the meowings so how do i get her to
understand that science can form true
beliefs about reality as it really is
ah young man you're asking
what is the foundation of knowledge ah
yes well hold on to your chapel i'm not
wearing a chapel it is just an
expression
sorry all knowledge must rest on a
foundation
that we can never doubt and that is
of course so we learned that the theory
of knowledge poses some very serious
problems
excuse me professor erickson i've done a
little reading since last we spoke and
i'm prepared to show you that everything
we know about science is true
well i'm all ears you said i couldn't
truly know anything but there's one
thing that i do know
if i question i must think i think i
must exist
cogito ergo sum i think
therefore i am
you're right you're darn right i'm right
guys give it up for sheldon
[Applause]
now for a job well done
here is a flower full of sweet nectar
why would i want that
because you're a butterfly and this is
just your dream i'm not a butterfly
are you sure
it was a dream oh no
help i'm a butterfly nothing i know is
real
everything is a dreamy missing hell
no
[Music]
missy am i awake or is this a dream
shut up dingus okay i'm awake
[Music]
shelly you feeling all right yes
how come you're not dressed why should i
because you're gonna be late for school
i'm not going to school
why not because i don't know what's real
what does that mean
dreaming and waking life and death
philosophers and butterflies
they're all the same nothing matters
that's an interesting way of looking at
things
george
get up and get dressed i don't have time
for this nonsense what is time
what is is she took a philosophy class
and won't get out of bed because he
doesn't know what's real anymore
mind if i put on mtv doesn't matter
we're all gonna die anyway
deep thought dingus a new young sheldon
watch next thursday or stream anytime
on cbs
[Music]
foreign